טוב.
אנחנו נמצאים
בביתה של דוקטור חיה בר אלי ברחוב ויצמן
בתל אביב.
היום יום ראשון,
בדצמבר,
חייב
את גלידת קדרה
ספרי קצת,
אולי.
מה הזיכרון הראשון שיש לך?
קשה לי להגיד זיכרון ראשון, אבל
מי אני?
הזיכרון הראשון, זה של ילדי מושבה שמשחקים ברחוב
וכדור
בכלל. אז
באבנים
אין
כוכבים על חמורים.
מספרים עליי שכשהייתי קטנה
נעלמתי יום אחד
ו כשהעדר
עם הפרות חזר. אני חזרתי עם העדר,
שאל אותי מה מה את עושה. אז אמרתי שהלכתי לטייל עם הפרות.
אד,
בת למשפחת בילויים, ממייסדי גדרה.
נכון.
ספרי קצת על המשפחה,
על המשפחה.
אני סבי וסבתי.
מצד אבי
זה שלמה, זלמן, צוקרמן
ורבקה.
סבתי
היא האחות של יהושע חנקין
ו
את תסבלי סביב. נפטר
מאוד מוקדם.
אני אני הייתי ילדה.
תודה.
הוא נפטר ב.
אני חושבת שהייתי ילדה בת שלוש
והיה הזכרונות שלי ממנו. הייתי יושבת על ברכב. הוא היה מספר לי סיפורי תנ ך.
סבתי לעומת זה
הייתה
היא איבדה בת.
אבי היה תהום.
הייתה לו אחות
ששמה היה חיה.
שאני אשמה אני נקראת
בסבתי.
היא קיבלה את זה מאוד קשה.
אבל
בסופו של דבר היא התחשמלה והייתה אישה נחושה
ניהלה לבדה את המשק
כשהיא הייתה הולכת להשגיח עליה
בציר. בקרן
הבאה עם שלישייה
והפועלים אומרים הפרשות בר תיזהרו.
סליחה.
את הקשוחה
הייתה אישה קשוחה.
קשוחה כלפי
כלפי חוץ. אבל למעשה היתה אישה.
אה?
מאוד טובת לב.
מה היה משק? מה קלה למשק של סבתך?
המשק של סבתי
כלל בעיקר קרן
קרן
ענבים,
אבל היה גם אם ומאכל וכמובן בתוך.
ובאמצע הקרן הייתה טעינה
ענקית
ששם היינו מבלים ואוכלים מהפרי. זה היה משהו
יוצא מהכלל.
ומלבד זה
אני כבר אני לא זוכרת איזה משק היה לה מקודם.
אבל
בזמני
הייתה הפרה שנותנת חלב. היו תרנגולות שנותנות ביצים.
רוצה לצרכים של המשפחה, אזרחי המשפחה. והיה לה גן ירק
שממנו כולם היו נהנים.
ואתה מחלק את לילדים? לילדים.
אבל הפער מה מקור ההכנסה העיקרי היה הקרן.
כן.
חוץ מזה, לא היה פרדס. היה
זוכרת אם לסבתי היה גם כן פרדס
לנו לאורה
להביא היה פרדס
פרדס וקרן
איך אביך הפך להיות
גם
בין מושבה ים.
אבי
הוא
סיפור מיוחד.
אני
בזמן מלחמת
העולם,
אתה יודע, הראשונה, הראשונה
לראשונה
היי תנילי
במושבות
ו
את
נאמן, בלקין מרעיש ריימונד בלתי
כן,
אנחנו היינו מקורבים, המחותנים הבלתי נמנע.
ואז הם חיפשו את הצעירים שלה
של המשפחות.
ואבא היה
היה בחיפה. אמרו שבאים לעשות חיפוש, ברח לחדרה בחדרה, ברח לגדרה. וככה
היה צריך להזהר.
הוא היה כותב את חבר נילי או שלא.
לא היה לך את אמילי.
בסופו של דבר, הוא
התנדב לגדוד
העברי הראשון.
השליש השלישי לא משנה עכשיו להיות הראשון ליהודה. כן, כן, שאפשר להיות הגיעו למושבה,
אבל הוא כנראה אולי יכול להיות שהוא נמלט מהטורקים.
לא בגלל ניל, אלא בגלל שהוא לא רצה לי להיות בשירות צבאי. הרגישו אז גיוס חובה.
כן.
וזה היה מאוד נכון. מעשית, אנחנו גם כן. כן,
הבנתי.
עכשיו
היא
המשק שהמקום שאתם גררתם בו היה חלק מהיחידה של הסבתא שלך או בחלק מהמשק שלה.
בניתם את אתכם שם. אביך בנה אותו? לא
אבי קיבל. אז
שמי קרן קימת היה הפרויקט של קרן קימת
כשחילק
אדמה,
ו
וקרן היסוד עזרה בבתים
לבני מושבות.
זה היה רחוב שלם שהם קיבלו. במסגרת זאת, אנחנו בנינו את הבית.
אז אם היה רחוב הראשוני הרחוב הזה שבו ברחוב
הבילויים עולה למעלה והרחוב שלנו בצד בצד יותר.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו אני
יודע פחות או יותר איפה הוא גדל.
אז את היית איזה בת
את היית בת הבכורה,
בת הבכורה. וכמה מעבר לך היום?
היה עוד
בן
אחד
ביניכם.
אז את זאת זוכרת את אנשי באילוף ש
ואותך היום בזמן אם זה ובריא כאן,
אתה יודע איך זה בעיקר נשאר המין החלש. אנשים,
רובן היו נשים.
הקברים מוצבים מנשה מאירוביץ'
ו לייבוביץ.
דב ליבוביץ'
ש
אתם מאוד שומרים על קשר צאצאי הבילויים
אני
אתה יודע מה? זה ממש עצוב להגיד
שכבר
גם הצאצאים אינם
כן. פשוט בודדים. איזשהו נשאר? כן.
מגדרה, לפחות
אני
מה אני אגיד מיש בקדרה?
שלושה, אולי שניים?
שניים?
מסגרת לוב
סברדלוב אליעזר ספרד לא
ו
טוב, הרגשתי
מי הורגש אולי עוד אחד.
אני לא זוכרת מי השני וישנא שמה קרסני. שהם לא היו בילויים אבל הם היו מהראשונים
אני לא זוכר מי עוד יש מלבד לעזר
אני חושבת שזה קורה בבניין
הייתה עליה אבל
איך היו החיים?
היו הייתם
לא הייתם עשירים אבל החיים היו בסדר חייתם בסדר.
איך את זוכרת את ילדותך? לא היה מחסור
לא,
אני לא זוכרת נעשו
אבל תשמע
למרות שלא היה מחסור הייתם בעצמי או
כן
הייתם בצניעות
היינו בצרה אם
איזה
צעצועים היו לך משחקים
הלילה היה חסר לנו מישהו חסר שלום
הבלתי נמנע אבא שלי היה
קשור מאוד לחנקן
לבל כינים והן היו נוסעים לחוץ לארץ הם היו
במצב טוב והיו מביאים לנו מכל טוב
בבגדים
משחקים
הבנתי.
אז
בית הספר היסודי למדת בגדי רע בבית הספר היסודי? כמה הייתם בו? מחזור בכיתה שלך?
במה הם
בכיתה שלי
או שחברו שני? שני מכשירי שנתון עם יחד
ככה
למדנו
שתי כיתות
ביחד
את אחת המורה לאמת, ואחת עשתה עבודה עצמית והיא התחלפו,
ובכיתה היינו
בסופו של דבר
היו כמה מורה התחלפו. אני זוכרת את הסוף שנשארנו בכיתה הזאת.
שלושה ילדים
קיס איננו לפי התקדמות וכדומה. אז נשארנו שלושה.
כן,
יפה
ו
למה אתם שפות זרות? גם
אנגלית
לא התאמנתי,
רק אנגלית
ערבית. ידענו קצת לדבר. משחק יום יום מערבים שפגשנו
ערבית, את יודעת, היום גם לא
אני מבינה, קצת, מבינה?
אבל לדבר ממש אני עבדו אצלכם, אבל
עולים ערבים,
כי
אצלנו במשק
אבא העסיק
עבודה עברית.
תודה.
היה אצלנו
פועל
בגבעת ברנר,
גר אצלנו בבית
יקותיאל.
ומה זה אהבנו אותו. היה לשרת. נשאר לנו הבעיה כל השבוע
אבי ניהל את גנוואר בוק.
זה פרדס של דבר ברוק האמריקאי,
שזה
דונם על יד,
בית הגון
ב
דרגון,
בג'ק, בדאגות,
בבית הגדול. כן,
אז
הוא היה בא,
תמיד היה חוזר הביתה
והוא היה. הוא היה עוזר לנו בשיעורים והיה מלמד אותנו שירים. ומה זה היה אצלנו?
כמו בן משפחה.
אז הוא היה מיקי בגבעת ברנר, קיבוצניק, וזה היה מר.
היה מקובל ש מישהו מהקיבוץ, תא פלוגת עבודה ש
שיצאה ועבדה במשק הן,
והוא היה ישן אצלכם וחוזר לקיבוץ בסוף שבוע.
בחור נחמד, כנראה. כן,
נחמד שווה שאמרת איתו על קשר. אחרי זה
הרבה שנים שמרנו
על קשר. כן,
אפילו את הבן שלא הכרתי.
כן,
וגם עבד,
אבל גם פועל ערבי.
מחמוד,
קטרה.
קטרה
ו
מעניין.
כשהם
היו עזבו את המשאבה, אבי היה
מפקד הביטחון בגדר.
אז אבי אמר להם
אל תברכו,
תישארו, אני מבטיח לכם שלא הייתה לכם. אני מדברת על ארבעים.
כן,
לא יקרה לכם כלום.
בכל זאת באו הם
המנהיגים שלהם, המסיתים שלהם.
הם עזבו
את המפתחות של הבתים שלהם. הם נתנו לנו
לאבעיה מבטח מהבית. בקתה ומהבית ומשמיע
של החברים שלו שעשה קית.
וכמובן,
הם
כן
אחרי
נפגשתם פתאום?
כן.
אבי היה
מושל צבאי
של
מגדל גד,
והאיזון של קן יתבל באתגר
אשקלון.
כן,
ואז שהם שמעו שהוא המושל הצבאי,
אז אחת הערביות
שעבדה אצל סבתי. הרבה שנים
באה
אלא
גדר
ואמרה
אני
על
משפחת
צוקרמן, המושל,
תגידו לו שאני רוצה לראות אותו.
זה הילד שלי.
אז אבא נתן רשות להכניס אותם. והם נכנסו,
נכנסו,
נכנסו.
הם עבדו איזה זמן. אני חושבת שהוא סיפר להם שהם יוכלו לעבוד. הם רבו ללחם
ואחר כך הם חזרו,
חזרו לאשלייה ואז
לעזה.
זאת אומרת
בהתחלה עם מתגובות באדג' במג'דל עוד איזה שנתיים, אבל שרק בחמישים או חמישי
בדיוק הם פונו לרצועה. רק חמישים חמישים ואחד
ממנו לעצור
את זה.
היחסים היו ב תקינים עם הערבי הסביבה.
תראה,
זה מורכב. אני יודע שזה מורכב.
אם קטרה היו יחסים טובים,
אבל עם מריו
ומסיעים ומשמיע,
ו
מה
שייך מהם?
ואחר כך
ועל כפרים אחרים, היחסים היו שם.
היה הם
לא טובים
לו. טוב,
כן,
זה מה בזה כחובתי זה התבטא
קרמפ או בצעדים פליליים, או שהיה לזה גם מספיק לאומני?
תראה,
הם היו נוסקים, כמובן,
וההסתה הייתה לאומנית.
זה היה בעיקר על רקע לאומני,
והם פחדו. פשוט פחדנו לעצמם.
היו מאויימים?
כן,
זה
זה. מה
אז הייתם בקט.
את יכולת ללכת בתור נערה צעירה, ילדה, ללכת ל קטרה להסתובב שם,
או שזה לא היה דם לפני המורה לפני המעורבות, כמובן שאלה.
כן. איזו שאלה היינו אמר
הם היו מארחים אותנו, היינו הולכים לבקר אותם.
כן,
בהחלט
כן.
לפני
מה עוד
ספרי ככה. איזה
הנגד? אותות מאותה תקופה מהתקופה של הילדות. אולי
משחקים משותפים עם
אמא. בני הכפרים השכנים,
טיולים משותפים,
טיולים אלה?
לא
תראה
מה שאני זוכרת מבית הספר, אבל שזה ככה חצי הנגד אותי
עשינו טיול מבית הספר בגדר
הכיתה יותר גבוהה בכיתה שלנו
על חמורים.
ואני היה לנו היה חמור
מאוד גבוהה. דבר יפה.
אז בא אליי אחד הילדים ואומר לי
עצמי את החמור שלך
למורה
ואת בואי תרכב איתי
והוא היה שובב
ידוע
אז הוא היה אומר לי התכבדי אותי חזק
היה עובר עם החמור
לפני החמורה,
הטון
של המורה והיא היתה מעמידה רגליים למעלה וזורקת אותו
והוא המורה, המורה, הוא היה קו רץ מהר מקים אותו.
אחד הדברים שאני זוכרת
זה
מעשה קונדס. כן,
היו מעשה פקודת בבית ספר היו סמים למורה צפרדע בתוך המגירה
בבית על המושב
דברים כאלה, כישורים רגילים
שיש שהם רגילים
אני
בתקופת המאורעות
את בטח זוכרת גם את מאורעות
היית ילדה קטנה, נכון,
נוראות עשרים ותשעה אמרתי, מה קורה בחולדה? שמע את ושניים
כפר אוריה אתה
בן טוביה
מאורעות
אספו
את כל בני המושבה. היינו
מתים נפש בסך הכל.
אספו את הנשים
והילדים
לתוך בית הכנסת.
ו
לילה אחד
ראינו
באר טוביה בוערת,
ולילה שני אתחול, זהו ערך
ואז הקים אותנו. מהלילה השלישי
היה עליית גג דרה
שבת
ג'ו רש,
כשהיו אלו לאדמה, אם הבילויים,
והיו נאמנים ויעבדו במושב.
והם אמרו
אם אנחנו נשמע שהולכים להתקיף את גדר, נודיע לכם, אנחנו נעשה מדורה
על ראש האחר שלנו.
ואז הם הדליקו את המדורה
מפני שהתכוונו להתקיף את גדר אחרי חולדה. בבאר טוביה היו הצלחות כאלה.
אז
ראו את המדורה, הכניסו את כולנו, הקים אותנו מ המזרונים, סגרו את החלונות במזרנים
וחיכו להתקפה.
ואז
רואים
ולגדר היה טלסקופ כזה שהיו רואים בו
מרחוק
ואז רואים בלילה.
שי םאה
שלי
זה
כמה אוטובוסים
בא
לגדר? מכיוון מר מהכיוון תל אביב
ואני
היו בטוחים שזה באים להתקיף אותנו.
ואז
שלחו
מרגלים
לראות
את שערן עמדה שם
לראות מי ומי הבאים.
ואז
מתקרבים
אבא שלי.
איזה
על זה הסיפור שאני זוכרת שאבי אבי סיפר
התקרבו לשיירה
והם שומעים מדברים אנגלית
אז הם קיימו והזדהו
ואמרו טוב שהסתרתם אנחנו חשבנו לחזור הכל חשך לא ידענו לאן לנסוע
טוב,
אז העבירו אותם למושבה
בבוקר היתה שמחה וששון
אני הייתי ילדה בלונדינית ישחקו איתי קלאס ונתנו לי ממתקים אני זוכרת את
החיילים הבריטיים
והם למעשה מה הם באו לפנות את המושבה
תודה
אז סבתי
אומרת לאבי
שאתה תדע
אם אתה
מדבר על פינוי, אותי אתה משאיר פה
אני לא הולכת,
קשוחה הייתה סבתא לא פה,
ואז אף אחד לא התפנו
נשארו כולם במושבה.
בסדר, אם
פינוי יום קודם בתחולדה כן,
השאירו שם את הפריים צ'יזיק, את הגופה שלי
רגע, רגע,
רגע, רגע, רגע, רגע. מיקרופוני זה מעשה
אם
אם כן
מהוראות
היו בהחלט
אירוע שחרט ככה היה חוויה
חוויית ילדות שאני זוכרת אותם זוכרת את זה פעם ראשונה שתיגש לזה
לאחר ש מיליון איום ביטחוני כזה בדיוק על יום
יום ביטחוני אספו אותנו כמו שסיפרתי לבית הכנסת
וכשראינו את חולדה ובאר טוביה נשרפות. הרגשנו איום רציני
מאוד. בעיקר, שהקימו אותנו מ המזרונים. וסתמו את החלונות.
כן,
זה יהיה
והחוויה, אפילו הזאת,
לשמוע ששערה מתקרבת למושבה ושחושבים שזאת הסירה שבה להתקיף אותה.
ובסופו של דבר,
כמו שאמרתי,
מה זה היה?
היו
היה צבא בריטי
ש
באה
למושבה,
נשלחה להגן על המושבה.
למעשה, אם יש לך לפנות אותם.
מי עסק בזה?
יהושע חנקין.
ששמעה
שיש איום על דרה,
הוא
הפעיל את כל הקשרים שלו ונשלחה הקבוצה הזאת לפנות את קדרת כמובן שהגדרה לא התפנתה,
אף אחד לא עזר.
ואני
והעובדה הזאת שבה
באו להגן על הגדרה,
גרמה לכך שיותר לא התקיפו אותו
היה גם לגדר לבחורים של גדרה. הם כולם היו
רוכבים מצוינים,
קלעים, יוצאים מן הכלל.
והערבים העריכו אותם ו פחדו מהם.
למשל, כשהיו גניבות,
הם לא היו מוותרים. הם היו
הולכים
לכפר,
מוצאים את הגניבה ומחזירים אותם.
והם היו מפחדים. הערבים היו מפחדים מהבחורים שהיו באים לדרוש את מה שמגיע להם.
כך שהיחסים עם דרה
היו יחסים מיוחדים,
והיה לה גם שם
בקרב הסביבה.
כלומר,
היה לכם אבל שמירה קבועה. מי שמערער על המושבה
ברור שבמו הוראות היה תגבור. אבל מי ששמר על המושבה באופן שוטף תשמע,
אני
הייתה שמירה בעיקר
בימים,
בימי מאורעות.
ככה אני לא זוכרת שאני לא אולי לא מודעת לזה. מה שהיה בדיוק.
אני מתארת לי שהיו גם אולי שומרים ערבים מהם.
אני אספר לך עוד דבר. בימי מאורעות
אבא שלי
ימשיך בעבודה
בעבודת הקטיף
בפרדס שהיה לנו.
והוא עשה את זה תוך סכנה
כי
כולם ידעו
כשהוא
מפקד קדרה
ובשר כנופיות
רוצות אותו.
עבדנו ואני הייתי אז חופש.
עבדתי גם כן בקטיף
עם
בגדרה, בפרדס שלנו
ו
פתאום
אנחנו שומעים יריות,
כולם
נשכבים על הרצפה
והם ניסו להתנקש באביך.
מה את אומרת? כן.
איך קראו לאביך?
עשהאל
צוקרמן
ישראל? יצאו כלום.
ניסו להתנקש באביך.
ואז
היה מפקד משטרה
בגדר
שהיה
גר במושבה
אצל יהודים.
למרות שהיה ערבי, הוא היה אוהל יהודים.
הוא הגיע לבית והרימו כוסית.
וכולם כמובן באו, הרימו כוסיות לחיים,
שהוא
לא נפגע.
ואני
זהו,
אנחנו
הבעיה. איש מאוד מאוד אמיץ.
והוא בכלל
לזכותו.
היישובים בנגב.
שני
אני רוצה לא ללכת עד הסוף. במוצאי יום כיפור את מדברת? אחד השר המצפים הראשונים שעלו
לא המצפים הראשונים אלו כבר ב
אותה כבר אלו המצפים,
כן,
זה הפרטיים וגבולות. ולתת אשל הם אלו קודם הם נמנעו ב
על כל העבודה שלו?
כן,
ואחר כך עלו
באש מוצאי יום כיפור תופשים זהים?
כן,
העבודה שלו
של אבי,
הכל קניית התרגום חינם הוא קנה את הקרקעות שעליהם הם התיישבו.
הועסק בקניית קרקעות בנגב.
היה לו
דודי, אך אבי המכור
יואב
עשהאל תשמע את השמות.
יואב עשהאל צוקרמן היה משרד לקניית קרקעות בנגב
והוא הם אולי,
אבל
הוא היה מעין
מסונף לקרן קיימת.
נכון?
אז הוא רכש קרקעות שזה כל כך את הקרקעות האלה
נגד
וכפר מנחם
גבולות.
ואנחנו היינו הכיר את החבר'ה שם. הם שהוא היה לא רק שהוא קנה להם את האדמות,
הוא היה
יושב במקום,
עושה להם את הקשרים עם הערבים בסביבה
איך ליצור לימד אותם איך ליצור את קשרי הידידות עם הערבים יחסי השכנות.
ואני יודע רבי טוב
על גוריה. קרוב, טוב.
כרוך טוב גם כן.
אבא שלי הוא
התחלתי אז לספר עליו הוא
המחזור הראשון של גמנסיה של
בית הספר הריאלי.
בית הספר הריאלי בחיפה? כן,
הוא נסע ללמוד, שלחו אותו ללמוד בחיפה.
וזה אז אני סיפרתי לך שהיה עניין של נילי. הוא היה צריך לברוח
שם
משפחת בלקין
אז הוא היה במחזור
הראשון של הריאלי, אבל הוא לא סיים, לא עשה את הבחינות תעודה
בגלל המלחמה שפרצה ואחד לוחמת העולם הראשונה?
כן,
אז הוא קנה
את כל הקרקעות
ליישובים, כפי שאמרתי לך.
ואנחנו
יש לך עדיין תעודות מעל זה? יש לכם תעודות? מסמכים, הדבר הזה
רגע, רגע, רגע
אחר כך,
אחר כך.
אחר כך נצא. יש תעודה שלא רק שיש תעודות, אני כתבתי ספר על אבי
ושם
יש צילום של התעודות.
יש לך עותק מזה? בטח.
טוב,
תזכור גם את זה.
זה
אני.
אני ממשיך להתקדם קצת בכרונולוגיה
עם הגיל,
ואנחנו מגיעים לשנות השלושים.
היה
שוב תקופה של מתיחות. הפעם מתיחות ארוכה יותר.
מאורעות?
כן.
איך זה התבטא אצלכם בגדרה?
את כבר לפי חשבוני. התחל תיכון כבר
אני התחלתי ללמוד בתיכון על עמדתי בסמינר לוינסקי,
ו
בגלל המצב
לא הייתי נוסעת יום יום, וגם כי
זה היה קשה.
הייתי בא הביתה רק לשבתות,
ולבוא לשבת
הביתה
באוטובוס.
זה היה סיכון,
כי המכונית האוטובוסים היו יורים עליהם
והיו הורגים,
נהרגו מייקרים וקרובים, ו
זה לא פשוט איפה הסגור? הרבה בתל אביב,
בתל אביב. התגוררתי בתחילה אצל אחות, אימי,
אימי, אחות. אימי בלה
הייתה נשואה
למשה דפנה
משה דפנה שכתב את אודי חמודי כן,
ובין אביטל
כהן,
והוא היה
מפקח
על בתי הספר. הוא היה מורה. הוא היה משורר,
אז התעוררתי אצלם איזה זמן, ואחר כך התגוררתי אצל חברה.
מי
התנועה ממחנות העולים שהייתי חברה ב
שילמת מי זה שכירות שלממשלה יש בוודאי,
אבל
יפה. אז
את
הסכומים לך? איזה אירועים מהנסיעות שלך מהמאה ה
מהסינר
חזרה לגדר היו רגועים מיוחדים
אני
לא
אני לא זוכרת שהיו לנו אירועים
מיוחדים המבנה היה לנו מזל ולא ירו עלינו
באף מקום.
הנסיעה הייתה הולכת מגדר דרך מראה הרחובות דרישות רקס הרפר את רכבת בדרך הרגילה.
אם
אם היה משהו מסוכן בדרך זעם רב
כן
אמרה. ידעת. עברת מר הזה הכל. אבל זה בסדר.
זה בסדר. דברים היו ידועים. כן, כן.
אתה יודע
שלמדתי באוניברסיטה בירושלים,
אז
מי
ההוראות?
אני
אבא מטלפן ואומר
תבואי הביתה
לסוף שבוע או
משהו כזה.
אני מחכה לך ברחובות
מלאה. בעיה מזה שהוא עבד בנגב?
היה
ג'יפ לבן
והיינו קוראים לו הג'יפ של עבדול קאדר חוסייני תשוקה עושים קדר היה כזה.
זאת הדרך, חוסייני, שהוא
היה המפקד הנוף נוחיות שגם כן היה לו איזה ג'ייק לבן.
אז זהו. אז הייתי בעל
רחובות, הבעיה מחכה לי
והוא היה נוהג ואני עם אקדח וכך היינו נוסעים.
עכשיו
את בטח גם כן כמקובל באותה עת היה הפך להיות חברת הגנה.
תראה,
אני הייתי למעשה חברת הגנה בגדר. אה,
כן.
ו
לא במקום אחר
כשהייתי בתל אביב. אז כבר לא הייתי
לא הייתי חברת הגנה
כבר הייתי נתונה לדברים אחרים
גם
אחרי גדר. אז כבר לא היה לזה אותו טעם
והגדרה.
הבנות
שהיו בהגנה
היינו אתה. תהיות על המגדל
היינו שומרות את הקשר. דר' היתה הנקודה המרכזית גושית.
היינו שומרות את הקשר של
בעיטות,
אתה יודע,
הייתם למעלה למגדל,
מסתכלות היה לכם שעות קבועות להסתכל לקשר עם כל אחד מהזה?
או שהייתם רואים, הבהוב, האורות והייתם
הסתכלו כל הזמן מסביב לקלוט מפרקים
אני
היינו פחות או יותר היינו מסתכלות.
והיו גם דברים שהיו כאן ככה יותר קבועים. וידענו שיהיו.
זה מצחיק. אבל למשל,
היינו יכולים כבר מנחם
לקבל לברק
שלחו את הרופא הפרה חולה
תשלחו כך וכך, כאילו עגבניות ומלפפונים וחצילים ואספקה. אספקה
זהו. אז אנחנו שמרנו קשרים של חיי יום יום ממש וביטחון עם
היישובים שהיו מסונפים לגדרה, כנקודה המרכזית גושית. גם
אתם הייתם כפופים לרחובות.
אתם הייתם כופרים לרחובות. זאת אומרת,
המסקנה של המחוז היה ברחוב.
טוב,
יפה. אז הייתם עושים משמרות יום ולילה למגדל
היו ביום היה עליון גרף היה קשר. ואם היו אבנים ואם היו עננים
אני לא זוכרת שנתקלנו בבעיות
הקשר ביום לא כל כך היה
היה חזק.
הקשר עיקר הקשר היה בלילה
באורות.
מה שאני זוכרת כן
הקשר עם ההוראות
כש
נקבע
עלתה
על האדמה.
ואני
אבא נסע עם השעירה הזאת לנגב ב
ואני הייתי על המגדל ושמרתי קשר
עם נגדה. ואם היה לכם קשר עין גם אם נגד בך
כן
כיוון
יפה.
הו,
את הקורס עבר כמו סוור בגדר אסור לכם לתת הם עדיין
המונים כאלה דעת לקצב טוב, היה לך לא היה לך בעיה
לא היה
בהם
הכל היה
שרה
יונים לא היו לכם לא
בודדה?
בסדר,
מה המברק הכי דרמטי? שעתיים. זה שהיה צריך להעביר
הכי דרמטית
אני לא זוכר לא משהו לא זוכרת משהו
במיוחד שמעתי
כן
היה
להיות על המגדל?
כן,
לפעמים היה בזה סיכון? לא תמיד אבל
היו פעמים שראו את האיתותים מהמגדל
שהיו יורים על המושבה אז היינו מכוונים אלינו
למגדל
כמה פעמים
ירו בתקופת המעורבות? זה קרה בערעור
אצלי בחדר שלי בבית נתקע כדור?
כן,
כן.
מאיזה כיוון יבואו אלייך?
אני
מהשבט הבדואי.
לא אני חושבת שאז
שאז כבר
קטרה.
נשלטה על ידי הכנופיות. ציוד
זה ירוק כנראה מתנשאת שזה קרה.
כן?
כן.
כמה זמן נמשכה
מערכת האיתות שלך? כמה יצטרף? תשמע,
זה נמשך הרבה זמן, אבל
אני
הפסקתי את זה כשאני למדתי בתל אביב. אז אני הייתי רק בחופשים. מצטרפת אליהם.
זה לא היה לך בעיה אחרי הפסקה של כך וכך זמן
צ'יק צ'ק
עכשיו אמנם אני שכחתי אני לא חושבת שאני אוכל לעזור
להיות התשתית,
אבל אין
בזמנו שצעירים אז זה דבר שלא נשאר לך כמו הירח הם גם
תחנת שידור לא,
זה לא היה
זה רק מאוחר יותר.
הוא קם
יפה,
למדת
בסמינר,
גמרת את הלימודים בסמינר,
ואז באופן
טבעי את רצית להמשיך הלאה בלימודים גבוהים יותר.
אני למדתי בסמינר.
לא סיימתי אותו.
הייתי בחברת מחנות העולים,
הפסקתי והלכתי להכשרה לשנה.
כן,
הייתי בקיבוץ משמרות
רשמי
וכולם הלכו. אז
גבעת עדה, ואחר כך
ל עלול ליישוב חדש
לך מדיה.
ואני לא הצטרפתי. אני חזרתי, גמרתי את הסמינר והלכתי לאוניברסיטה.
לא התאימו לך להיות קיבוצי? כי
לא
בסדר.
היכן הכרת את בעלך זל?
את בעלי
הכרתי במחנות עולים.
בערך.
אני
הכרתי אותו במחנות עולים, ושם דווקא הייתה.
לא הייתה איזה ידידות מיוחדת,
רק אני.
שנים אחר כך
נפגשנו שוב אחרי הלימודים,
כשאחרי האוניברסיטה באוניברסיטה
ומאיפה במקור
בעלי עלה לארץ.
מליטה
בגיל שלוש
אני
בשמו בר אלי
המשפחתי. אבל
הוא קודם הורם.
היה להם שם אחר הברוד.
אבא שלו
היה המנהל הראשון של בנק הפועלים,
ואמא שלו
הייתה.
אני חושבת
שהופעת
אף אוזן וגרון יחידה בתל אביב. בזמנו
הם עלו ב.
אני חושבת,
לפני היאך וויניק כמובן. אבל לאחר כך
הוא
והוא.
בעלי היה
מאוד בהגנה
מחנות העולים. פעל,
היה
בהכשרה, היה בקיבוץ,
וכמה די היה חבר קיבוץ
כמה שנים.
כשאני עזבתי את ההכשרה
כזה באסיפה, שהודעתי שאני עוזבת,
אברהם עופר
אמר לי
שאני בוגדת
ושאם הוא יראה אותי
או יעבור למדרכה השנייה,
עבר הזמן.
וגם הוא עזב.
ואז
אני רואה אותו מאחור הולך ואני תופסת אותו מאחור.
ואני אומרת לו הר
תעבור למדרכה השנייה
איך הוא הגיב? צחק מה זה?
היינו מאוד בידידות, ובעלי היו חברים מאוד טובים.
היו היה מבאי ביתנו.
כן.
זהו,
זהו.
הלימודים שלך החלו.
האם לא סיימת
את הלימודים בתיכון שלך?
אז איך התקבלת לאוניברסיטה?
לא חזרתי מאוד
אז חזרה אנחנו לקיבוץ. חזרתי וסיימתי היום.
אז
בהפסקה. קילו של שנה. אז כן,
בעצם
בדיוק אמרתי מהחברה שאם עם המחזור שלך גמרת מחסור אחרי.
נכון,
הבנתי.
אוקיי.
ואז את מחליטה ללכת לסוציולוגיה ללמוד סוציולוגיה. עבדתי
קודם לפני שהלכתי ללמוד סוציולוגיה. עבדתי כגננת בראשון לציון,
שזה גם כן הייתה
חוויה מיוחדת
ביישוב, במפגש עם בני מושבות,
עם הנוער של המושבה
על החולות של ראשון.
וזה,
זהו.
אבל
כמה זמן איש היית גננת עד שיצאתי ללימודים?
שלוש שנים,
שלוש שנים. נספק להיות גננת.
אחר כך הלכתי ללמוד.
התחלתי ללמוד
ופרצה מלחמת השחרור.
התחלת ללמוד
ופרצה מלחמת השחרור?
הילדים שלהם, הנפשי
שהיית שהיית גננת שלהם גדלו,
פוגשות אזעקה אותי
עשיתי.
פגשתי
ילדים,
שני ילדים שמאוד אהבתי.
נפגשתי איתם במקרה באוטובוס.
ואז עשינו מפגש
של
הכיתה
איתם.
כן, היה מפגש מאוד מרגש
בצוות.
יצאת ללימודים בירושלים. איפה יתגורר בירושלים?
בחדר סחור
תצטרכו
כן בבית המעלות.
מה הערה הביא אותך ללמוד סוציולוגיה.
איך היה לך תמיד נטייה לזה או
לא,
זה
אני חושבת שבתקופה הזאת שעבדתי כי גננת אז פיתחתי ככה את התחושה הזאת.
אני
רוצה
לסוציולוגיה
וגם תוך כדי לימודים באוניברסיטה
בין הלכתי לשמוע כמה מקצועות,
ובסוף היא בהכרח לכיוון הזה. הלכתי לכיוון הזה
בירושלים, התגוררתי בבית המעלות.
רוב הזמן היה לי חדר
פעם פה, פעם שם, אבל בבית המעלות
ו
באחד הימים
זה היה כבר המתח עם הבריטים.
אז
זה
מה זה היה?
כן,
בשמונה.
זה
יכול להיות כבר ב
כי כבר ב
גם רגעים השאלה הייתי בירושלים, ואז היה כבר מתח עם הבריטים.
אני חוזרת הביתה
אזעקה,
ואני נכנסת
בין
שני הבתים של בית המעלות.
יש ככה
פתח שמכניס לאיזה רכבה, ואחר כך אפשר לצאת ממנה.
אבל
זה לא ככה. בדיוק
שכחתי. הסיפור לא הולך ככה. הייתה אזעקה.
אני יצאתי מבית המעלות
ו
כמו שאני יוצאת, ואני עומדת
בלובי,
אני רואה
שני אנשים
מוציאים מכוח
בכוח. מושכים מהמעלית
אדם שלישי
שפניו
זבי דם,
והם מצליחים לנתק אותו מהמעלית.
ואישה
צועקת צעקות נוראות,
והם יוצאים החוצה
בדיוק לתוך
ג'ייק.
בריטי
מוציאים,
ואני יוצאת אחריהם. ואני
הם מוציאים אקדחים,
יורים על
הג'יפ הבריטי.
אני נכנסת בין שני הבתים.
הם פצעו כנראה את אחד הבריטים. הג'יפ
הסתובב וברח.
רגע, רגע. אני רוצה להבין מי שיוציאו
מישהו.
שני אלו שסחבו את הבנאדם היו
חמושים. חמושים? אבל
היו לאזרחים לא היה נשי. לכי,
אנשי לכי.
אנשי לחם
משכו
קצין יהודי יהודי
שהיה נשוי לאנגליה
אוקיי
ואז
כשהם יצאו מול מול
הרכב הבריטי
הם התחילו לירות עליו והוריד.
הם
הסתובבו וברחו. אני בזמן העיריות נכנסתי בין שני
הבניינים. עמדתי
האיש חזר הביתה,
נכנס לבית המעלות והם
עברו על ידי שניהם לתוך הרחבה הזאת והיא סמכות.
ואני ברוב טיפשותי שהייתה המהומה ואנשים דיברו. וכך
אז אני אמרתי אני הם עברו על ידי אני יכולה לזהות אותם אז מישהו אמר לי תשתה כדי תסתמי את הפה
זה עזר.
זה החוויות של ירושלים. החוויות של
חוויות שלא
יכול להיות שהצלת אותו ממוות. אני יודע,
אתה השוטר היהודי הזה כי
אם הם היו עושים דברים כאלה
שעשו את זה
מעניין, כשהם משכו אותו להוציא אותו ושם ואני הסתובבתי אני רואה מה הם עושים לו
בפניו זבים דם אמרתי להם מה אתם השתגעתם
וכולם מסתובבים,
יפנו אליי,
אבל שראי
בי ברגע זה
צץ לי מה קורה והם יצאתי החוצה.
הבנתי.
ו
חוץ מהחוויה הזו איזה היו איזה חוויות היו לך מול הבריטים?
הייתה לי עוד חוויה מול הבריטיים.
הם
הקיפו את מושב מולדת
לעשות חיפוש.
באו לעשות חפוז במושב מולדת.
ואז ההגנה ארגנה
את כל הנוער מכל המושבות.
באנו,
ישבנו על החולות. היא
הקפנו את המקור.
מדברת על שכונה את מולדת. כן.
לא מושב מולדת, לא לעלילה תחתון, אלינו שכונה פולט. זה פה ליד חולון, נכון?
אז
הקפנו את המקום, ישבנו
ושרנו שירים על הכלניות, והתווכחנו איתם וכדומה.
ופשוט
נתת להם לזוז?
הם היו יכולים כמובן להתגבר עלינו אם היו הם נשק בזה.
אבל
זה היה
מכשול
בארבע שעות.
מה שזכור לך גם גם הדבר הזה, זה הדבר הזה. זה החוק.
ובירושלים אחת לכמה זמן היית חוזרת הביתה בכל סוף שבוע, בדרך אגב שעברה? בדרך כלל,
כן.
כל סוף שבוע
הלימודים היו קשים.
עבודות ספריות?
כן, אבל לא.
לא התקשתה במיוחד. אהבתי מאוד את
הלימודים.
מתי סיימת?
מתי קיבלת את התואר?
סיימתי ב
קיבלתי תואר
מוסמך
אם ה
ואז לא היה אותו ערב.
בילי
היה שלם ישר להם. מי? הלכנו
טוב, מוסמך. כן,
ועבדתי
איזה זמן
אסיסטנטית.
נתתי תרגיל
באוניברסיטה עצמם.
מי זה?
אני קצת קשה לעקוב אחרי שניהלתי ילידת
ב.
היית בת עשרים
אחרי שש שנה אחת
הלכת להכשרה גם כן. שיגבה אותך
כמה שנים. תוך כמה שנים קיבלת את התואר
ב
קיבלתי את התואר
הזה הוא אמרת ב
כרגע
ב
היה המקרה הזה עם על אוקיי,
אז אני הבנתי מהדברים שלך שבבים שלוש קיבלתי את התואר
וזה לא הסתדר ארבעים ושבע קיבלנו עתה זהו עכשיו זה מסתדר
אז ב
כן
בסדר עד
הוא היה בהרבה ושלוש
בין שלוש היית בת עשרים אז נראה קצת מוקדם
לסיים את הלימודים
אז
באים לשם
למדת שלוש שנים
לאוניברסיטה ארבע שנים
ממש תואר
מוסמך םי םי היה צריך ללמוד
שלוש ארבע שנים
כן,
קמעה קמעה
כמה החוג שלך מנה? כמה ראיתם?
מה אני אגיד לך
למעשה
היינו שניים
אני וחגית רגר.
הבת של אתה יודע מי היה רגר
ויקב?
הוא היה מנהל מחלקת החינוך
כלומר
לא הכרתי לא הכרתי
כאשר
היה מנהל מחלקת החינוך
וזאת היתה ביתו היינו שתיים
שהמורה העיקרי שלנו. זה היה
שמואל איזה שטן
ו
יאנינה
גרבר טלמון
אלה היו המורים
מורים יוצאים מגדר הרגיל
מורים נהדרים
כן
ו
אצלם עשינו את העבודות
עשית גם עבודות בהר
כרכי העבודות לקראת התואר בטח היית צריכה לעשות גם
עבודות סימס שמוק רוחות
לשאול, לפגוש לראיין. וזה
מה את זוכרת מה היה הנושא שלה עבור העבודה שלך?
מה היה נושא העבודה שלי?
איך? אני לא זוכרת.
לא זוכרת כרגע
כן,
בסדר
דומה
במה עסקת אחר כך
אני חושבת
בדיוק בשעה שהעבודה שלי הייתה
מאחר ואני
לימדתי בבר אילן,
אבל זה אחר כך בריא לנו. כמה מאוחר יותר,
מתי
מה ברגה
בה,
אבל לא עבדתי בבר אילן.
למיטב זכרוני, ביער אילנות לא היה בגובה.
בדיוק
אני ואלי עקיבא עבדנו. רכיבה דויץ',
אבל זה לא ברור. אם זה הוא, אז
אז אני מדבר על השנים האלו עד ברילנד. לא,
אני לא זוכרת איזה עבודה עשיתי. אולי כתבתי משהו על דרה. אני לא זוכרת
על המושבה.
לא זוכר בדיוק.
אז
ברגע שקיבלתי את התואר,
עבדתי
באיזה זמן בסמינר לוינסקי
ואחר כך
לימדתי בבר אילן
שנה.
האמנתי. דורות שם.
כן.
לא, אתה לא היה ההתמחות שלך. איזה
ההתמחות שלי
היה
תנועות נוער,
ובעיקר עשיתי עבודה שהשביתה בנוער דתי ל דואר
לנוער לא דתי
ו
אני
עוד מה עשיתי עבודה?
לאיזה מסקנות הגעת?
מעניין.
חשבה בין הדואר הדתי ואני לא דעתי. כן.
לא יודע.
מסקנה די מתקבלת על הדעת שהנוער הדתי
היה הרבה יותר לאומי,
הרבה יותר
בעל
ערכים
וערכים לאומיים.
והנה
טוב, והיה יחסים יותר
של כבוד למשפחה, אני יחזה מן חופשי, וכל הדברים האלה
לא האמינו. בזמנו
בבר אילן נתנו לי להעביר שאלוני
שואל על יחסיי מין וחברות וכל זה. אבל
גבר זה העברתי.
כן,
עברתי יפה והייתה התייחסות לזה. הייתה התייחסות.
היה
לא היתה לי שום בעיה.
לפחות
שנה. זה
כן.
באיזה עוד פרסומים היו לך בתקופה הזו?
אתה יודע מה?
אפשר לקום רגע?
עוד לא עוד. ואז אחרי זה,
לא נעשה עוד מעט
היא
ברגע שאת ציינת, ברגע שסיימת את התואר, כבר לא היית מעורבת בענייני ביטחון יותר. בכלל.
היה לך פתח את חיים חדשים בתחום האקדמי. נקרא לזה מה שאתה אומר.
נכון?
יפה. היה הרבה מסילות לכנסים, לחוץ לארץ
והרצאות בכנסים בחוץ לארץ,
מפגשים עם מדענים מארצות אחרות,
וזה היה מרתק.
ומתי נסתם?
ניסיתי
זה.
התחלנו את הרומן ב
ניסינו.
באמת
יפה.
כן,
יפה מאוד.
אז קודם גרנו,
הוריו כבר נפטרו של בעלי הסגרנו
בדירה של הוראה.
איזה זמן? ואז קנינו את הדירה הזאת. הוא מכר את הדירה שלו, שהיתה לו
מחוץ לדירתו רב. היתה לו דירת רווקים, ואני מכרתי את דירת הרווקים שלי.
איפה הייתה עליו?
היתה לי דירה
אילו
הייתה לי
נבחרנו, זוכרת?
היתה לי דירה ברחוב הפרדס
פרוויס בתל אביב, לתל אביב,
על יד גן החיות. זה היה
זוכר.
אז הוא מכר את שלו ואני את שלי. אם קנינו את הדירה הזאת,
אני זוכר שהקימו את הבית הזה או אין. אגב, אנחנו נכנסנו עיניה.
לא היה כביש ולא מדרכה. ולא שום דבר. וראיתי
כל הים.
כן,
הכל היה פתוח
לאחר פה.
יפה מאוד.
יש לך ב
מה לדעתך
עיצב את ה
אחד? אם את אם את מנסה לעשות
סך הכל מ צוות את
הרווח שלך, את התרבות שלך, את הדעות שלך, את זה אחד.
מה את יכולה
להגיד על זה?
תראה,
אין שום ספק
שהשנים של המושבה
יצוו
את הקשר החזק לארץ, את הקשר להגנה, לביטחון
כל הקרדיט ל
לגדר על המושבה ולהביא
כן,
אבי,
הייתי נוסעת איתו בקניית קרקעות.
הייתי
מעורבת איתו
למשל,
לא סיפרת על הדבר הזה. בואי תספרי קצת על הנסיעות, על האלוף.
כן,
אבי, אני הייתי מאוד קשורה לאביך
והוא
למשל,
היה
באו הבריטים לחיפוש בקדרה
לחיפוש של נשק
אני
אביא
השאיר את הנשק בבית
תחת הקו.
הוא לא היה שוכב לישון בלי
כלי הנשק תחת הכרית. בטח.
ואני
ראיתי שהבריטים באים לעשות חיפוש. לקחתי את הגדר ושמתי אותו במצבן.
הרבה פיות או, באמת, באמת. כבר ידעתי שזה הנוהל זה מה שעושים
אני
אביא
היה קונה את הקרקעות,
קנה את הקרקעות
כמו שאמרתי לך ללא
גבולות לנגב
ולכפר מנחם
ואחר כך לכל הישובים בנגב
ו
אנחנו היינו נוסעים,
נוסעים מתו הרבה פעמים היה לוקח אותנו היה מאוד מיודד
עם בני הקיבוצים
שלהם. הוא קנה את
זה בשבילי, ואמו קנה את הקרקעות.
היה לו חדר
בקיבוץ.
איזה קיבוץ
אני
למשל בגבולות.
היה לו חדר
בינג בה
היה לו חדר,
ואז הוא היה עושה את העבודה
שלי,
ריכוז הקרקעות לאותו יישוב
והיה קושר להם את הקשרים,
עוזר להם
למוכתר שלהם מאמן אותו. מה זה אומר? נשמע שהקיבוץ היה עולה על הקרקע.
זה היה בעצם כשהיה לו איזה מין משבצת קטנה, ולאחר מכן הוא היה מרחיב עם היישובים.
אבל זה מעניין, כן,
וגם את הקשרים עם השכנים. הוא היה עוזר להם
להקים
מספרים לפגישה כזו היית
את לא הבנת מה מדברים כי הם דיברו ערבית? בטח.
אז דווקא אז הבנתי אולי ערבית יותר ממה שאני מבינה היום.
כן,
אבל
תשמע,
העבודה עם הערבים
היא עבודה מאוד קשה.
הנה
הם חתמו לך
ואחרי רגע הם נסוגים.
והיה צריך
הרבה עבודה
של שכנוע ושח עוד
ולא ושל איומים ושל ליטופים
בהרבה.
לנהל את כל העבודה של זה שהוא יודע עלינו, יודע אתה יודע. הוא היה אמן.
עמלנו היה בעבודה הזאת,
כמו שאחי אמר לי לפני זה ימים. ישבנו, דיברנו על אבא. זכי אמר
הוא היה יכול להיות קשוח כמו
אבן
פלדה
כמו צור,
ומצד שני הוא היה יכול להיות רך
וממש להזיל דמעות על עניינים.
אז
יצאת איתו להנמה המסע הכי ארוך שאת זוכרת איתו.
אני זוכרת נסיעות איתו
לגבולות
ולנגב אף
לא צריך החוק. כן,
הוא לא צריך, נכון?
כן. הייתי איתו בגבולות כמה פעמים.
והיה ערבי אחד שחור
הגוף לאפל
ש
הוא היה
היה מיודד איתו.
וגם אנחנו
משפחה. איפה אמילי? שזה היה? אני אני
אני לא זוכרת אם זה היה בנך. באו בגבולות באחד מהמקומות האלה.
ומה עם הצדדים הביטחוניים? הוא היה גם אמרת שהיה מעורב בזה? כן,
היה
בהחלט מאורה.
ו
הוא
למשל, כשישוב כזה עלה. אז הוא גם נתן להם
ההוראות ו
יכין אותם וסיפר להם איך לנהוג.
איך
הוא לא היה מוכתר של גדר.
הוא היה אולי מוכתר של גדר
בשנים
מוקדמות קודמות.
לא היה,
אבל הוא היה הוא
היה ועד המושבה של גדר
היה בוועדה מושבה. זו בושה.
הוא היה מהפעילים שלהם?
כן.
ועד מתי סבתך ערך החיים?
סבתי נפטרה
בגיל
הסביבתי. צוקרמן
בגיל.
היא נפטרה.
לא
במושבי. משמעה שנעשו? כן. אבא נכנס
כי היא גרה לבדה
והיתה לה' גינת
ירקות. והיא הייתה
ממלאה, יצרה חייה. והיא הייתה
יורדת בבוקר לגינה ומוציאה את הירקות שהיא צריכה לארוחת בוקר וארוחת ערב.
יום אחד
אבא בא ומצא אותי
בגינה.
לא במטבח. במטבח.
כן.
ו
וסבא ומשפחת. איך מצד
אימי? אימך?
משפחתי מצד אימי.
זה מרדכי אנקין. זה הסבא,
הסבתא היא לאחר
כן,
מרדכי אנקין
עלה
עם הבילויים, אבל נוהל
לא היה. החבר בילו,
אבל לא עלה יחד איתם.
והיו
חילוקי דעות על זה שהוא רצה להיכנס ל
שהוא לא היה באגודה ורצו להכניס אותו לעבודה.
אבל הוא נחשב למילואים מפני שאמרו וביחד איתם למעשה התחיל את כל העניין
יחד איתם.
והוא הוא היה מוכתר של בדרך
ובזמנו
הוא היה איש
חברותי מאוד,
ידע לקשור קשרי ידידות
ו
גם עם האנגלים שהיו אז בזמן מלחמת העולם הראשונה.
אבל
הבריטים, שנלחמו בטורקים, הפציצו הגדרה
ופצצה נפלה אצלם בבית אצל סבא, סבתי וסבי. כן, כן,
בביתם
ו
אחד
האנשים לא מגדרה שהיה אצלם נקטעה ידו.
זה אני,
סבי.
כן, כן.
מה שאמרתי לך. הוא היה
מוכתר של גדר,
והיה
איש מאוד
פתוח וישר. יפה.
זה
היה
חבורה הייתה מסתובבת סביבו
ושם שתי שפות. היי,
נשארו הנשים האחרונות
בגדר?
ו
כן, שתיהן היו מסתובבות ברחוב
גמול
במרחק לא גדול אחת מהשנייה. והיו הולכות מבית אחד לבית השני מבית אחד
יושבות על הספסל, לא מדברות. והן
זה
ו
מאורעות במורה אות
אני חושבת זה היה
אולי זה כבר היה אני
לא
מה זה היה ש
הרגיזו את גניה, בני?
מתי זה היה ש
ש הפגיזו את גן יבנה כיצד
המצרים הגיעו עד גן יבנה.
לו זה במלחמת העצמאות, מלחמת אחים את עצמו זה היה מלחמת העצמאות.
דיברנו. דיברת על שתי הסבתות שלך שבמלחמת העצמאות
כאשר הייתה הפצצה המצרית על גן יבנה. ואז מה קרה?
כן היו מסתובבות ברחוב,
היו קוראים להם השומרות של הרחוב.
יום אחד אני אז
הייתי גרתי כבר בתל אביב,
מלחמת השחרור.
עבדתי
כאן,
ואז יום אחד
ראיתי ברחוב
נשים וילדים מגדרה. שאלתי מה קרה. אמרו לי פינו את הנשים והילדים מגדרה.
למה? מה קרה? הצבא המצרי הגיע עד גן יבנה ומפציצים
את גן יבנה.
אני לקחתי חופש ונסעתי לגדרה.
באתי לגדרה
וכמובן פגשתי את שתי הסבתות מטילות ברחוב.
אז הם אמרו תנו,
מה, באת עכשיו, עכשיו באים
אני אומרת נעלמה. מתי באים?
אז סבתא אומרת תנועה
דוס השתייך.
כן,
גם אז
כן.
ו
למה באמת בשד? לגדרה, מה רצית?
אתה יודע מה? כשאני שומעת שהגדרה בסכנה, אז איפה מקומי בגדרה?
אז
באתי, זה
איבדתי ובאמת היו
ההפגזות על גן יבנה
שהיו מזיזים את גן יבנה.
השמשות אצלנו בבית היו מועדות.
היו הפגזות
חזקות.
עכשיו
זה
אז
באמת
היה הדיבור מה לעשות
אם לפנות את הנשים והילדים או לא לפנות את הנשים והילדים.
ובאותו לילה שאני באתי והיו הפגזות כל כך
חזקות,
אני
הייתה סכנה
של פריצת הקו
על ידי המצרים.
ואז
במשאיות
גייסו את כל אלה שלא היו מגויסים
לקחו מכל הבא ליד
נשים ולנסות לשים בחזית,
לסגור את הקווים שלך הזאת. לעשות חסימות פיזיות. אני יודע.
לקחו את רחובות אנשי רחובות וזה
ואז ייקחו גם את אנשי גדרה. את כולם.
עכשיו,
באותה
כשאני הייתי בדיוק באותו יום הערב שאני בא, הבנתי שלקחו אותם לעשות מכשולים נגד הנגד.
רכב טנקים לא כחיילים
לילה כעובדי ביצורים.
אני לא יודעת.
לא ידענו בדיוק למה לוקחים אותם אבל וחשבנו שלוקחים אותם פשוט לקהל לחזק את הקווים ברור,
זה יהיה.
ואז באמת הייתה יותר
דאגה. הרגישו את
הדברים, הסכנה מתקדמת
ו
אז אני חושבת ש
הדפו אותם
והסכנה ירדה
ואני חזרתי לתל אביב.
שתי הסבתות שלך לא חשבו בכלל להתפנות לא בשום אופן שבעולם הזה.
אתה יודע מבינות כמה הם היו
הם היו נשים זקנות
שיניים
לא
יותר. יותר משבעים? כן
יותר משאני חושבת
זה
מה זה לא בא בחשבון להתפנות היה
שם?
כן.
והם אפילו אני אומרת לך כאילו ברחוב.
כאילו, בעיה
תוקף.
לפי זכרוני,
אתה הזכרת קודם את לכי
בגדרה.
לכי עשה פעם אחת בחדר
באמת
חצר אותו. זה איזשהו קורס
שלו. את ידעת על משהו? על פעילות של כיבי קדם
לא ידע
מה
היתה איזו תקופה שעשו שם
בלי זה.
את לא זוכרת? את לא יודעת מי זה.
בסך הכל אני חושב שכיסינו לא רק
את
הסיפור, היא שאלה אם יש לך עוד.
מה את אומרת היום
על
המצב בכך החברה בארץ?
טאריק כמה מהדברים שאת אומרת כל הזמן מדובר על ערכים ועל
זכויות, על נשמע
מה אני אגיד לך
הילדים של בעלי.
לבעלי יש שני ילדים, בן ובת.
לא הילדים שלי.
וכשאני התחתנתי איתו, הם היו עדיין ילדים. את מי בבית הספר
ו
הבט למשל
לנסוע לחיות בחו ל.
זה היה דבר מובן
לגבי
מעניין שאחר כך שהתבגרה
יותר.
אז כי היא אמרה
כששאלו אותה אני לא זוכרת כבר את הקשר,
שאלו אותה.
אז היא אמרה
עליי
ש
אני
חיזקתי את הקשר שלה לארץ
ש
לפני זה לא היה לה אותו קשר לארץ
האהבה ואותה החשיבות לארץ בחייו, כמו שהיה
לפני.
אני ניסיתי מאוד להחנות את זה לילדים,
והצלחת
ניצלה.
חשוב,
חשוב.
הבן בהחלט כבר
ביניהם. היא תמיד היה יותר קשור.
כן, הארץ. מה עושים הילדים?
הבן
הוא מרצה להיסטוריה.
תודה
אל הציונות דברים ו
אוניברסיטת באר שבע
הוא חוקר
בתחום של הציונות,
ואני
מפרסם, כותב, מרצה של האחרונה. ראיתי אותו ביום, אני עכשיו מקשר.
הוא לא השתתף באיזה כנס.
לפני
כמה שבועות ב
נסה להיזכר. איפה הייתי?
אתם באוניברסיטת תל אביב. אולי לא להיות. כן.
כן, כן.
אבי בר אלי.
אז הוא
ממשיך
בהחלט בדם בדרך.
גם בדרך של אבא שלו. כותב
סוציאליסט
כמו שהיה אבא שלו בהשקפות.
והבת נפטרה.
צעירה
לא מספר
חמש שנים.
כן.
איזה זמן אחר. כמו בעלי
נפתרה
שלא תדעי יותר צרות.
טוב,
מה אתה אומר על הראיון?
חושב שזה היה
פתח לנו צוהר,
אתה יודע, מאוד מעניין.
תודה.
זה
באמת אני מודה לך על האירוח ועל הזמן שייקח לנו.
אז אפשר לתת לכם כוס קפה עכשיו?
אני לא.